so they say the first rule of show
business is to give people what they
want and on this channel is seen what
people want is Bruce Lee my Bruce Lee
training video has been by far the most
successful one on my channel getting
over 1.4 million views which is insane
so thanks very much for that so I want
to make more on Bruce Lee I did one on
his philosophy and I thought it would be
time to cover his diet going into this
avoid that I was going to find that much
that it was gonna be a relatively quick
video but actually as I researched more
and more I turned up Bruce Lee was
taking quite a popular new traffic stack
and that his supplementation in
particular might have shed some light on
just how he would say quick sit strong
and had such a low body fat percentage
so stay tuned and let's dive in
[Music]
okay so we'll start at the basics of
Bruce Lee's diet on the face of it he
ate a pretty standard diet all things
considered he was big fan of Chinese
food he likes more than Western food
that's just a matter of preference his
probably lactose-intolerant
he didn't like milk or dairy okay a lot
of steak apparently and he drank loads
of tea a man after my own heart there in
terms of what he did from a nutritional
standpoint one interesting thing is he
said that he ate regularly and in
smaller quantities this is something
that's argued among fitness enthusiasts
and fitness bloggers some people say
that it really doesn't matter what time
you eat as long as you're eating the
right quantities and the right things
other people say that meal timing can
have an impact some people only eat once
a day that warrior diet involves eating
just one meal and then being in a fasted
state for the rest of the time Bruce Lee
on the other hand ate lots of smaller
meals and the idea behind this is a that
it gives you a consistent amount of
energy B it's quite practical it means
you're gonna be bloated or full of
eating or going to work out on a really
full stomach and see if the bunny keeps
getting a good supply of energy then
hopefully it learns that it doesn't need
to store that fats and anyways the
excess fat is not there to be stored
basically you're giving the body as much
as it needs for the task in hand that's
all they expect forwards Bruce Lee also
didn't believe in empty calories he ate
a very nutrient-dense diet so that means
that he wouldn't eat anything highly
processed that provided no benefit to
him so he wasn't a big fan of baked
goods for instance that means cakes and
biscuits and things like that because
they were just sugar and they were no
nutrition no minerals no vitamins etc
again there are people who will say that
that also doesn't matter if you follow
me ify I am if it fits in your macros
diet that's often promoted on body boom
calm then you're able to meet your
macronutrient targets that means your
protein your carbohydrates your fats all
in the right quantities the right number
of calories and as long as you reach
that amount duly the gaining muscle will
lose weight and they say it doesn't
matter if you eat donuts all day as long
as you don't surpass that
that you can steal this way and that is
true but it's also very important that
you do eat all your nutrients and I'm
completely with Bruce Lee on this one
because is he research what all those
vitamins and minerals actually do for
you the Omega threes your Luton's
etc if you've read my website you'll see
that all of them have such amazing
benefits for you whether it's preventing
you from getting ill or whether it's
fighting information whether it's
improving your mental accuracy whether
it's improving your reflexes all of them
do something they're like supplements
they're just as good as supplements
they're like power-ups and if you can be
getting that from your diet why would
you just eat stuff that is just clogging
up the system and not providing any
benefit and Bruce Lee in accordance with
this would also supplement with
additional multivitamins and
multi-mineral tablets and he
particularly supplement with vitamin E
which is very good for its antioxidant
effects so protects your cells they are
prevented from getting ill and it also
fights inflammation which is also very
important information has been linked
with poor mood though mental ability and
other problems so yeah Bruce Lee was all
about getting lots of new useful
nutrients in his diet and not filling
his diet with just junk your processed
food so I'm sure he would occasionally
treat themselves to something nice as
well that's all fairly standard it's all
advice he might come across regularly
even though there is some minor
controversy around some of those points
but you know eating a balanced diet high
in nutrients and not stuffing yourself
that stuff that nobody can really argue
with too much but what's much more
interesting is that Bruce Lee also
supplemented with some other interesting
ingredients so he would take a protein
shake and right away that's a big boon
for anyone who's a proponent of protein
shakes if Bruce Lee did it then it can't
be all bad right so protein shakes like
multivitamins and multi minerals aren't
necessary you can get the present from
your diet even better but protein shakes
are a very convenient way to get the
protein that you need and to but not
spend a whole lot of money on meats not
spend ages cooking not have things going
off in the fridge so just
anyway to get yourself that protein that
you want Bruce Lee was possibly
lactose-intolerant he didn't like dairy
and say he used powdered milk instead of
regular milk with that entirely optional
what's even more interesting than just
the protein shake itself though it's all
the interesting additions that Bruce Lee
would throw in there so he would use
inositol apologies if I'm saying that
wrong
granular lecithin so if I'm saying that
all wheat germ
peanut butter brewers yeast eggs with
the shells on bananas all in with his
protein shake blended up into what
sounds like a really disgusting mix and
I'm going to try it today because I
thought you know it's only fair isn't it
but yeah that might sound like just a
complete random concoction that he came
up with off the top of his head or just
a random selection of ingredients that's
all made up and he never really took at
all but actually if you dive in and have
a look at these ingredients there's
actually some synergy between them and
it seems apparent to me that he put a
lot of thought into it and that it might
actually get some way into explaining
his energy and his enthusiasm and his
speed even and that's why I went to
taking this video to take anything bruce
lee eight things that provide him not
only with fuel but sustenance he was
training like a madman he would go for
long runs he would do bag work heavy bag
work he would do weight lifting and
training martial arts and sparring and
then he would write for hours like he
was just a driven man and he needed all
that energy and you would need to
recover when he slept and that's why you
can't just be eating donuts and cake all
day you need the actual stuff that's
gonna help the bodies to recover and
repair that's gonna give you the energy
you need and Bruce Lee as will say all
the stuff he took made him very energy
efficient so yeah I'm gonna give that
protein mix a try and as I do I'm gonna
talk you through each one of those
ingredients and why it was actually a
really interesting concoction hopefully
okay let's start with the simple stuff
weight protein and like I say I'm not
going to be the power of milk because
I'm not lactose intolerant I would
normally actually have my protein shake
with water but Singh as you use house
milk
thought I'd use at least something close
and so now the eggs as far as I can tell
the only good reason to add the shell as
well is because it's 90 to 95 percent
calcium calcium likes a good for your
bones it's also good for your muscle
contractions and your tendons and
ligaments it's also potentially somewhat
synergistic with some of the other
ingredients we're about to look at
however I'm just doing it because I'm
trying to be authentic here of course
eggs are a complete protein good source
of choline all sorts of other good stuff
I'm just gonna put one in there because
that is definitely already gonna be
disgusting enough okay so next up is the
wheat germ this is also fairly standard
this is just a nutritious convenient
it's a good source of omega-3 bits mini
which as you said he seems to really
like and all bunch of minerals as well
so in goes
[Music]
[Music]
bananas of course a good source of
energy of the car hydrates also good
source of potassium so he would have not
got crap he helped to replace him of his
electrolytes after workout now putting
in the peanut butter peanut butter is a
great source of protein action some
bodybuilders use it it's also a good
source of various other nutrients it's a
good source of fiber especially if you
have the lung kind there's a smooth
contest where I could find it Marks and
Spencers and hopefully this one might
slightly increase the flavor it's also
good source of Newseum and copper should
bring good for muscle relaxation
actually just generally despite being
delicious very nutritious okay now I
have two slightly more interesting stuff
such as the inositol so I've got choline
I still hear that Bruce Lee just had it
not at all listed as is sometimes
slightly inaccurately referred to as
bitumen v8 but what it actually is is a
supplement that increases the ability of
the body to transport lipids and prevent
the storage of fat which of course is
very good if you want a ripped Bruce Lee
like physique and it also encourages the
body to use said fast as energy to pay
for energy metabolism what inositol also
does though is it encourages the release
of calcium in the brain which in turn is
crucial for the communication between
neurons by a neurotransmitters it
increases serotonin which helps to relax
the body and mind slightly it's good for
combating anxiety some people will take
an inertia tall supplement just before
an important meeting or interview as a
way to kind of calm themselves down
unlike something like five HTTP it
doesn't have the side effects of
potential tolerance and dependences
which is naturally inside the body you
can also get it from various food
sources such as organ meats like liver
as well as oranges and other foods so
it's perfectly safe but it's a great way
to reduce your anxiety whilst also
increasing your energy levels and that's
combination you don't often get you can
also
in heartlessly because it also acts on
GABA gamma-aminobutyric acid which helps
us to relax even more so it's a great
potential supplement for increasing your
energy metabolism your fat loss and your
ability to sleep and stay calm Bruce Lee
was a very chill guy wasn't me to say
you never know that something to do with
it and then we have the granular left
bin I'm sorry I don't know how it's
pronounced I've read it a lot but not
heard it spoken a lot say again I
couldn't get the exact version you had
I've got soya lecithin but same thing
this is again a supplement that has a
lot in common with choline this is
naturally occurring form of choline and
that's one of the things that makes him
think that Bruce Lee actually did put
some thought into this concoction
because this is actually a popular
nootropic step to combine enough Atoll
unless appeal or choline and lecithin
because when you have them together
they're synergistic and the increased
amount choline in your system more than
either one of them would do on their own
so again he was ahead of his time he is
taking the popular new tricks that are
poorly terrific sets were thing and the
reason you want choline increased in
your system other than the benefits of
the enough stuff I already described is
the coating as natural precursor to face
entire only what is the one of the most
abundant excitatory neurotransmitters in
the brain so this is used for
communications between almost all of
your neurons is particularly important
for memory and information retention
it's also the substance that crosses the
neuromuscular junctions there's a
possibility that this combo would have
increased his speed of muscle fiber
recruitment and his strength of muscle
fiber recruitment and I think the naviga
of the results potentially speak for
themselves as yeast which is the kind of
yeast used for making bread and for
making beer and this is great source of
B vitamins one through to seven and B
which means of course are very important
for getting energy from your diet so
this is another great way to boost your
energy metabolism along with everything
else in there so again it could help him
to burn more fat to have more energy
during workouts and on top of that it's
also got chromium in it and chromium is
thought to help to moderate blood sugar
levels to prevent you from having
to high blood Sugar's help you to
utilize the sugar in your system more
for energy so all these things they kind
of make pop bunch of cents when you
combine them together you have a stack
that gives you lots of energy helps to
burn fat helps boost your brain function
in your muscle fiber recruitment and
your contraction strength so seems like
you know what you're doing I'm going to
give it a go that doesn't inspire me
tons of confidence there because it's
still sound and looks disgusting
[Music]
okay bottoms up
here goes it's so much of it
[Music]
mmm it's dense and crunchy visually
clearly had a very effective blender
it's not that bad except it sort of is
it's so thick oh that's the gel capsule
so chewy surprised okay nothing nice it
didn't only be sick if I can seemed all
of this I don't even know I'm gonna get
rid of it because you block the toilet
and the drains and just the capital off
what I have here is a little royal jelly
Bruce Lee apparently used to drink a
concoction of ginseng tea with honey
that was made by the queen bees once
again I couldn't procure any honey made
by queen bees as far as I'm aware but
I've got a nice organic honey here and
some ginseng tea and this thankfully
tastes a lot nicer it's boiling hot
there it burns myself so the idea behind
that one ginseng is a adaptogen also
seems to be able to increase nerve
growth factor and it's near protective
and antioxidant etc hasn't been
thoroughly researched and the mechanisms
of action aren't fully known but in
general it seems to be a good way of
reducing stress and providing extra
energy whereas honey of course is a
supply of sucrose and fructose very good
kick of energy so who knows maybe if you
do need something to pick you up during
the day this might be a good concoction
to try I would say it's certainly a bit
invigorating but probably nothing
groundbreaking so it's decision time
should you consume a diet like Bruce
Lee's and
should you have a kind of crazy protein
shake like his I would say definitely do
not have that crazy protein shake
because it is disgusting and incredibly
thick and it has lumps of shell in it
that will check you I don't know if he
really consumed anything like that
however I would say that the individual
ingredients and particularly the
inositol and the lesser spin or just
choline in general are very beneficial
not only for your brain but also for
energy levels fat metabolism bruise
yeast with the chromium and the B
vitamins is also an impressive
combination and the biggest take-home
like I've said is just that consuming a
nutrient-dense diet will help to give
you the energy you need and the recovery
you need to kind of engage in the same
kinds of intense exercise and learning
and production that Bruce Lee did when
you think of Bruce Lee you think of a
guy who's just had this unstoppable
motivation this seemingly endless energy
he was quick he was strong and until his
end he was very healthy and that needs
to be backed up with a good diet high
nutrition and yes supplements can help a
lot I like that step but you know pick
your own if you're not a big fan of it
and make a three choline etc take from
it what you will as Bruce Lee would say
himself absorb what's useful and reject
the rest so you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did please
consider leaving a like and maybe
subscribe to the channel and hitting
that Bell button helps me out massively
and I leave the comment down below let
me know what you think of this dieting
of his interesting stack certainly
follow me on social media on Twitter and
Instagram and on Facebook where I'd love
to hear from you in future I've got a
lot more like this coming I think I'll
be doing a video on Bruce Lee's fighting
style because why not complete the set
I'm also going to be covering nootropics
in more detail once again of course of
interesting workout videos on the way
one about rocky Balboa's training and
lots of Technology productivity working
online stuff so if you think that sounds
interesting then stick around hit that
Bell button and stay tuned for the next
one thanks a ton for watching and bye
for now